for
e
good evening members and officers of the
council welcome to the meeting of the
Constitutional review working party bit
of housekeeping as usual if the fire
alarm is activated please vacate the
offices via the stairs do not use the
lifts and assemble in holy Square on the
green and officers will assist you when
it's deemed safe to return to the
chamber does anybody intend filming the
meeting no good no members of the
public could everyone please ensure
their mobile phones are turned to silent
and they're not used or to make or
receive calls in the chamber whilst the
meeting in progress please note that
this meeting is being live streamed for
members of the public except for any
items of business or exempt or
confidential information is considered
following the exclusion of the press and
the public from the
meeting would any member wish to speak
under Council procedure rule 20.1 please
announce it no are there any apologies
for
absence noneed by us none thank you
anybody got any Declarations of
Interest good I move that the minutes of
the previous meeting held on the 28th of
February 2023 be approved and signed as
a correct record could I have a second
please second Council
Austin unless there anyone else objects
to the minutes I will take them as
agreed thank you item agenda four is a
key decision definition and I'll ask Mr
use from the committee services manager
to present the report
thank you chairman uh so uh this report
is is here
um as part of the review of The
Independent monitoring officer uh we
recommended that uh the council scheme
of delegations uh needs to be easy and
clear to understand and includes
appropriate conditions requiring
engagement of counselors in strategic
and high-risk decisions so um as part of
our work on that um some members will be
familiar with with the office scheme of
delegations that we took through the
general purposes committee which is one
end of the delegation scheme and
ensuring that um counselors are required
um in the Strategic and high-risk
decision making that's what this end is
about about the key decision thresholds
so uh the key decision threshold is
outlined um at uh 2.1 of the uh of the
report or the current one
and the revised one is outlined at
paragraph 2.3 of the report so uh this
has been extensively debated by the
corporate management team uh and has
also been uh run past the cabinet who
are equally uh content with the
definition um essentially the main
changes are
um uh increasing the uh amount of
expenditure on
um property purchases from £750,000
to uh a
million and
um uh making it clearer that um the
acquisition of property is actually a
subsection of paragraph one uh as
opposed to be a standing alone um point
on its own if that makes sense um so I
can do some examples if people are
unsure of what we mean by any of the
things that are in there so so for
example we'll get um uh uh if we do
number one first so Council wants to buy
a a thing a uh a refuge Lorry for
example it's £300,000
is that over 250 yes it is therefore
it's a key decision nice and
straightforward that one
um uh the best example is
um for for the other starts of 1 A and B
is uh let's say the um uh a land trust
for example um and let's say we put 5
million into a land trust to go and buy
properties in thanet uh do them up and
and um make money that way um the
original decision as that's over
£250,000 would be a key decision because
we're spending £5
million then if we went out and
purchased a property
say for half a million
pound we would say actually one a comes
into uh effect there so we've cabinet
have already given their um permission
for us to spend A5 million you don't
need to go back every time you want to
spend some of that money the money
that's already there with the exception
to that is if one of the properties is
over a million pound because that's such
a massive amount of money for one
officer to go out and spend officers are
not comfortable spending over that
amount of money so that would be a
separate key decision and would have to
go back to Cabinet okay um the point two
um again that's uh pretty
straightforward so if you have a a
contract that is
um uh £100,000 a year for five years
that would not be a key decision because
100 100,000 times five is 500,000 that
is less than the 750,000 threshold in
this which would be over its lifetime
not a key decision if it's £200,000
over 5 years that would be a key
decision because that would be a million
p and that would be over the £750,000
threshold does that make sense it's very
well good and then the last criteria is
um where it would have an effect on
communities in two or more Wards so that
is uh what we consider to be a
significant effect so if it affected
sort of a small amount of people into WS
that wouldn't really trigger this this
is more about the idea of it being a a
very high-profile decision that affected
lots and lots of the population of two
Wards um or if we think that um it's
going to be an enormously significant
impact in one single Ward that would
also trigger that uh key decision
threshold okay um so those are the main
changes um that sort of makes it very
clear for um what key decisions are
going to be taken by the cabinet and
it's really important to note that in
this Council it is the Constitutional
rule that officers cannot take key
decisions we cannot that's very clear
only cabinet or individual cabinet
members can take key decisions
um that's pretty much it really unless
anyone's got any questions
counc yeah um obviously as it says
cabinet um was happy with this um
proposal and
uh that won't surprise you in view of
the fact that it's here um but I just
wanted to flag up the fact that the the
benchmarking which has been done against
other um District councils in Kent which
I think is we shouldn't always do what
our neighbors do but uh I think in this
case looking across the piece and seeing
that we're well in the pack really we
we're not an outlier in either direction
gives us some comfort that we're in the
right place um and it feels like the
right place to me so I'm happy to
support
this any other comments Council scobby
yeah just just a couple of questions I
know there isn't actually any
relationship to um internal external
audit but it was a question for for
Chris what was the materiality that the
Auditors look at roughly when they're
thinking about the audit what what
numbers do they not not the word trivial
but materiality materials around 1.2
million to give you an idea the sort the
context of things that they would say if
there was an error in the accounts above
that level they would say that they're
not a true and fair reflection of the
reality of what's gone at the council um
triviality is closer to about £1,000 and
below that limit they'd say is of not is
Trivial of not of importance which I'm
not sure many people would share that
view but that's their testing
level Council scobby and then and then
just a second question um who defines
what the key decision is so obviously
you set out the criteria but even when
you're explaining it there there a
little bit of a gray area about you know
the financial side is clear but in terms
of the impact on the community you're
describing that if it was a minor impact
on two two Wards it would be considered
not a key decision but if it was a major
impact somebody's got to make that
judgment I'm just interested in who
we would generally um ask the decision
so the the officer who's doing the
report but we would ask them to think
carefully and if they needed advice to
come to um ingred as the monitoring
officer uh or me as Deputy monitoring
officer to to ask and seek advice on
that um and then if they weren't sure uh
I would sincerely hope that they would
be contacting their um at least their
head of service if not their director in
order to and then May Well Point them in
our
Direction and just to reiterate I mean
um Nick has described that perfectly but
it's obviously incredibly subjective
compared to you know and it's area
dependent but it's something to really
consider with you know in in the context
of the environment the are the
particular area and in context of
particular decision
so any other questions from
anybody no okay what
commendations and looking at the report
there's three options could members
agree one of the following
options 41A is to recommend the revised
definition of a key decision as per
paragraph 2.3 of the report to the
standards committee or B to recommend
other amendments on the key decision
definition to the standards committee or
C to recommend to the standards
committee that no amendments are made to
the key decision threshold yes counc
um I'll move that we uh adopt 41A then
to recommend the revised definition
Second all in favor for the
recommendation fine then the
recommendation will go through to the
next standards committee thank you very
much item agenda five is review of the
council's policy framework I'll ask Mr
use to present the report please
thank you chairman so uh again um this
is another part of the uh the work that
we're doing to make sure that we've uh
addressed all the concerns of the uh
independent monitoring officer and this
again uh is is part of the um ensuring
that uh councils are involved in
strategic and highrisk
decisions so
um one of those things that I've always
the people who have known me for a long
time have always been saying like one of
my things is Council take council's
decisions cabinet take cabinet decisions
and that in the main is absolutely true
however there is this thing called the
policy framework um and the policy
framework is a series or it's a list of
plans policies um that uh the council uh
deem so important um that full Council
decides those um or has ultimate final
say on those uh those policies and and
programs now um some of these are
defined in law others are are just what
we call local Choice functions so
theoretically if there's something that
members feel is so important um that
full Council should be the people that
decide that that we can opt to put that
into the council's policy framework even
if it is a something that wouldn't
necessarily go to council so what we've
done is we've refreshed this list
because this list is very old I think is
is probably best to uh way to describe
it um so you've got things like the
local transport plan um well that's now
a KCC function because they're the
highways Authority um and likey I mean
it must be at least 15 years since um we
were the highways Authority so it give
you a slight idea of um where we're at
with the uh the current list um so this
list again was reviewed by our corporate
management team um and again uh run past
the uh the cabinet so we are uh
proposing at paragraph 2.4 to take out
the local transport plan um that is one
of the plans that comprises the local
plan so that's already in as a separate
point so we don't need to include it
twice it seems a bit odd to put it in
twice um we've removed the housing
investment program uh having spoken to
the uh director of house uh director of
place sorry um he felt it was much uh
more appropriate to have specific polic
policies around housing in that in the
um policy
framework so that is why at uh four five
and six we've added the housing
homelessness and rough sleeping strategy
the housing assistance policy and the
HRA business
plan the food law and safe the food law
enforcement safety plan is um yeah
something that no one's really quite
sure why it was included in the um in
the um policy framework and then
interestingly enough in our benchmarking
exercises lots and lots of other
councils have removed the food law
safety uh food law enforcement service
plan from their their uh lists as well
now um it's uh very important to note
that this is not an exhaustive list of
things that go to full Council if
something in law says it has to be
decided by full Council it will still be
decid Ed by full Council things like the
budget for example setting the council
tax those sorts of things are Council
functions and they um go to full Council
but there's no need for them to be part
of the council's policy framework um so
that's it in a nutshell uh as before
we've got the three options if you want
to uh recommend it as it is great if you
want to tweak it you can do or if you
want to keep it the same you can do that
as well so if anyone's got any questions
happy to answer them
councelor
Austin um can I fulfill my duty as a
stereotypical green counselor and ask if
we should be including the climate
change action plan in our uh in this
Lis it's it's up to the views of members
however what I would say is uh you have
to be careful if you take something that
is currently an executive matter and
then put it as part of your policy
framework then that ceases to be an
executive function so if you've got a
climate
CAG and then you then decided to make
that a council function you wouldn't be
able to have a climate CAG anymore
because it's not a it would it wouldn't
be this the locus of of the cabinet
anymore so would change the way that we
run that whole function okay I I
withdraw the
suggestion and councilor scobby yeah I'm
I'm scratching my head a little bit
about this food law enforcement service
because the rest of it makes totally
logical sense you know housing issues
are coming up we want them to be on
there because we want um them got to
council some of the stuff's old that one
I don't fully understand because it is a
service the council supplies and it's
quite important in the community I'm not
suggesting that if it's not on council's
agenda that it's not important but just
scratching my head a little bit about
how that's been there left there and
what this change would mean
yeah I mean I've I personally don't have
any view on the food law and safety plan
but I mean I say if members wish to put
that back in they can do I mean to be
fair it's still a it's still a council
function so it would still from time to
time come to council but we wouldn't
deem it to be one of our most important
policies I think I think that's the way
that the policy framework Brands them as
one of the most important
policies
yes Chris Nick you may correct me if I'm
wrong from recollection um I believe
this is a plan that goes in the private
SE um would have to go in the private
session as well so because obviously
again it probably adds to make sense for
it go to Cabinet you could have it under
private there the scope for it to be
scrutinized through OSP rather than for
for me personally if I was advising it
it doesn't feel like a plan you'd want
to talk about and discuss at a full
council meeting you'd want to get into
the detail at cabinet through OSP rather
than discussing in around at council
meeting which again would be in private
session so it's not even as if you've
got the ability to provide public
transparency around it at a full council
meeting yeah I I I don't think in the
real world it's an item which which
council is an effective body to consider
and I think when it has come and Chris
is quite right and council's have to go
into private session to consider it um
doesn't make any sense to me I think it
belongs at cabinet and and and you know
members are if members have a particular
interest in it they're absolutely
entitled to come and and speak under
20.1 cabinet and interrogate it but um
it doesn't seem to me very happy with
the proposal um and you know if You'
like to assist I'll I'll move um 3.1a um
to recommend the proposed
changes Council Austin seconded all
those in
favor CH sorry oh god I've gotten
feedback there I don't know how that's
happened um just for a matter of
accuracy check materiality limit it's
not 1.2 it's 2.7 so it's quite widely
wrong not sure how I got that quite so
it was probably 1 .2 million a few years
ago um it's 2.7 now but triviality is
135 so I WR on one of
them
[Laughter]
you item agenda six Mr use could you
please introduce a report thank you
chairman so this is uh tidying up uh the
council question rules so uh
currently uh the wording I would
describe as slightly ambiguous in in the
sense that
um if a uh a counselor puts a question
in on topic X um they can't then ask
that same question within the next six
month period if a um member of the
public puts a question in on topic X
then the way that the the uh rules about
uh excluding copycat questions are not
written in a way that the subsequent
question that is the same as the one
that's already been asked would be able
to be rejected if that makes sense um so
what we're saying is
um we would like to make it absolutely
crystal clear that a c a question cannot
be put to council if it's been asked by
either a counselor or a member of the
public in the past 6 months because
theoretically you could have a member of
the public ask a question and then a
councilor would be able to ask a word
for word identical question at the next
council meeting and vice versa which
seems a bit odd um I don't think that's
the intention of the rules um at all uh
the other slight change is where we've
put validly received in the uh in the
wording is um also something whereby um
if you had a scenario where councelor X
puts a question in councelor y could put
the same question in even with that new
wording they you wouldn't be able to
reject the qu the second question
because the question hasn't been put at
the
meeting which is where we sort of
slightly got quite close to at the last
council meeting um so consequently by
saying validly received that catches the
count that catches it so that you can't
have multiple counselors all putting the
same question in at a
meeting but also you can't then ask a
question that either a member of the
public or or Council has asked in the
last six months as well if that makes
sense cool councelor Austin delighted to
hear that last bit because that was my
concern was to whether validly received
meant for this next meeting meeting
that's coming up whether it meant
somebody who'd not been able to pose
their question but it had a written
answer or something like that that's
great thank you I just wanted to check
about as it were right of appeal and I
know that sounds like a sledgehammer to
C Kracker nut but having had a question
rejected once which I was told was
identical to a previous question within
the last 6 months and it was my own
question and it was not identical but
the then monitoring
officer misund OD what I was trying to
say or maybe I didn't explain it very
clearly I wonder what what dialogue
there might be under those circumstances
or whether it's just a question of
that's it you you're
done so um the initial test that we do
is we will as them Services we look
through and we have all the questions so
all the questions that have been asked
in the last I think it's nearly 10 years
are on the council's website so you can
have a look at those um we will look
back over the last 6 months to make sure
that um um something's been asked uh we
also do a basic check so is it addressed
to a Cabinet member or a chair of a
committee if it's not it's rejected
because it just fails the test is it
more than the word limit again it's a
clear yes no black and white test um if
it's clear that that question hasn't
been asked we we pass it on to the
monitoring officer with a with view
saying we've checked we've done the
basic checks we think this is okay the
moning officer says yep that complies
with the scheme happy days if we are
thinking like o not sure this is a bit
similar we'll pass it on to the
monitoring officer they will then say
yeah maybe not maybe not if they're not
sure the final Arbiter is is Colin as
the chief executive and the CH the the
um the Constitution is clear that Colin
has the final say on whether or not he
feels that that question is
substantially similar to one that's been
previously asked there isn't a um
appeals process as such but even if
Colin does want to reject a question he
has to contact the chairman of council
as like a a second opinion type thing of
in the process of him saying I think
this is substantially similar as this
are you in
agreement then so that is there's quite
a lot of checks before we get to there
isn't a dialogue as it were with the m
submitting the question but there is a
dialogue amongst officers to check on go
okay great thank
you any other
questions yeah I've got a specific
question and like AIT of a broader one
on the specifics how do we communicate
to people and say it's been rejected but
here's the copy of the previous question
so then at least they have an idea of
what was asked previously do we do
that we um we we don't refer them to the
directly to the previous question but we
do say this is the same as one that was
previously asked so we explain we do say
why we don't just go it's rejected
thanks very much um we we're not that
abrupt no but I do I think it's a fair
point it is a fair point I find it hard
enough to navigate Council agendas and
try and find stuff anyway yeah I I would
put a star next to that which is that is
much easier to do if people don't leave
it to the last minute because what we
generally do tend to find as in all of
life is that we are exceptionally busy
between about 3:00 and halfast 5 on the
day of the um on the day of the uh
deadline for Council meetings and whilst
we will always Endeavor to be as full
and helpful as possible the sheer number
of questions that we get makes it not
possible for us to go and provide that
level of detail in every single case but
we'll always try our best to do
that and and then just on the broader
piece like I completely support this
change it Mak makes sense but I'm sort
of I'm trying to understand this
committee's first time I've sat on it
how this change has come here but other
ones that discussed or you know I've
spoken to you about Nick and we've
spoken about with the leader and other
things that people may want to make
changes how because because this this
makes total sense and it should be
supported but I just want to understand
as a Committee Member on here how does
how do other things get on here because
I understood that we're waiting to have
a new monitoring officer to come in to
do a proper review of The Constitution
makes sense but if we we are we able as
a committee while that process is going
on to make small changes to improve like
this
one um yes I mean generally we would
always advise somebody to either contact
the leader or the chief executive that's
generally how we um we will start doing
things we flag things that that Dem
Services find and I would say this is
the Dem Services one um and we flag that
with Colin and then if Colin is okay
with that we will then start the process
but if as I say I mean if if we want to
get instructions if something doesn't
work or feels doesn't work then by all
means contact the the chief Z and and
the leader and we can we can start
looking at
those Council Everett yeah it seems to
me a bit unsatisfactory that this isn't
formalized and perhaps as part of the
Constitution review it's something we
need to think about because it shouldn't
be in the gift of the leader whether a
change of the Constitution even gets to
the Constitution review working party
because it's not a cabinet function so I
don't see the logic of that but maybe we
can think about what the mechanism ought
to be because I think at the same time
we don't want lots of random suggestions
coming forward so
um can I just add that if there's a
concern about the working of the
constitution in any regard please raise
it with myself as monitoring
officer I think what you're trying to
say is that there's no body to approve
everything then put it to us for us to
to approve it to the next level to
standards committee we haven't got a
constitutional Review Committee I think
that's what you're trying to say am I
right I'm just saying there's no Clarity
I mean I think um councilor scabby makes
a very good point there's no Clarity for
other members of the council or even
members of the public should they be
interested on how things get here um so
I think we we probably need to think
about providing that clarity as part of
a general refresh of the
Constitution counc scobby yeah and I've
got a specific example really because um
Nick and I before the last council
meeting were having a discussion around
the petitions policy and what policy the
petitions so the petition coming from
the Ward that I represent and Nick was
supporting the petition going through as
fast as possible but effectively the
Constitution as it was was not helping
residents to bring matters quickly to
either Council or cabinet so we we
discussed that that's something that we
should look at and I think we spoke
about it rick councelor Everett we spoke
about it and it's something to pick up
like how does that go from if you know
let's let's say Council Everett you know
was busy with all the other things
running the council how does that go
from having a conversation with
Democratic services to being on this
agenda as something to actually review
because the same issue could happen with
a petition that somebody brings tomorrow
and you know we we made a really logical
change here to questions which will
immediately you know make an impact it'
be good do we have a mechanism to pick
that stuff up while also respecting the
fact the Constitution is the rules of
the council we want to make it really
hard to change because they're important
getting that balance
right can I ask is this a democratic
Services problem or should it come to
standards to consider what the
councilors are
saying sorry my view is that Nick and
and I could come up with something and
that we can feed that back to you and so
that there is Clarity in that
regard councelor Austin I wanted to uh
Echo what councilor scob is saying just
in terms of of other functional things
we have talked about and the leader and
I have talked about um ways of improving
our minute taking for example for
transparency and I understand I I asked
Nick about this because the leader said
maybe we can bring bring it to the
working party and you said no because
it's not actually part of the
Constitution so where does that sit how
do we do that sort of a thing that will
improve our functioning and improve our
transparency to the public but isn't
specifically constitutional you know
there's a question about I think about
where that sits and my other comment is
as one of the people who annoys you on
in the last hour before um questions I
will expect that somebody else will
already have asked my question and
desist are there any other comments
I think Council ever you've recommended
4.1a if I haven't I am now thank
you can I have a second to councilor
scobby in that case we support the
recommendation and forward it to the
next standards committee for onward
approval to the
council
thank you for attending the meeting and
that concludes I did I owe one apology
and that's to ingred for not introducing
you to your first cwrp meeting and I do
apologize thank you it's nice to meet
everybody